things are starting to get interesting
in the first video we set up a space
time diagram for my frame of reference
and started to plot things paths in that
space time diagram and then we thought
about our friend sally who right at time
equals zero is at x equals zero but
she's passing me up at a relative
velocity of half the speed of light in
the positive x direction so after one
second she has gone one and a half times
ten to the eighth meters in the positive
x direction after two seconds she's gone
three times ten to the eighth and then
we assume that she was part of a train
of spaceships so 3 times 10 to the 8
meters in front of her was another
spaceship and it's moving with the same
relative velocity relative to me or in
my frame of reference so at time equals
0 it's 3 times 10 to the 8th meters in
front of me but then at time equals one
if we take this point in space time in
my frame of reference
that ship is now it now has so t let me
write this
if we look at my space-time coordinates
t is equal to 1 second
and x
is equal to
4.5
times 10 to the 8th meters that's from
that's if you look at my space-time
coordinates but what about sally
space-time coordinates
well to figure out sally space-time
coordinates we go parallel to the
x-prime axis and see where we intersect
the t-prime axis but that's still t is
equal to one second this is t is equal
to two seconds this is t is equal to
three seconds so t or i should say t
prime is equal to one second t prime is
two seconds t prime is three seconds so
t
prime is equal to one second still and
so in general we can say that t prime is
going to be equal to t but what is x
prime going to be equal to
so x prime well to figure out x prime
you go horizontal to the t prime axis
and see where you intersect the x prime
axis and you see that it's 3.3
times 10 to the eighth
three times 10 to 8 meters and hopefully
this makes intuitive sense if it doesn't
pause the video and really think about
it because in her frame of reference
that spaceship looks stationary because
it's moving with the exact same relative
velocity to me it's going to continue to
stay 3 times 10 to the 8th meters in
front of her which is exactly what we
see so that's why it's x prime
coordinates stay 3 times 10 to the 8th
meters from my point of view it's
getting further and further away from me
at the relative velocity at 1.5 times 10
to the eighth meters per second so how
do we how do we translate between our
between our
x coordinates
let me do this in a different color
between our x coordinates and our x
prime coordinates
well you see for these examples where
we see x prime is going to be less than
x
and that should also make sense because
the especially for this case it's
stationary from uh from the s prime
point of view but it's x is continuously
increasing as time passes on
from my frame of reference from sal's
frame of reference from the s frame of
reference so if we start with x we
should subtract something and the
difference between the two the
discrepancy between the two is going to
be the relative velocity times time and
so for this particular example we saw
that 3 times 10 to the 8th meters
was equal to
4.5 times 10 to the 8th
minus the relative velocity 1.5 times 10
to the 8th
meters per second times time which was
one second and i didn't write the units
but if you write the units it all works
out and you get exactly this so
hopefully that's starting to get you
comfortable with having these two
coordinate planes
on or two space-time diagrams over on
top of each other and the reason why the
blue one is distorted is because it's on
top they're moving with a relative
velocity relative to what i'm
considering to be a stationary uh
frame of reference which is mine
obviously there's no such thing as an
absolute stationary frame of reference
and we'll talk more about that in the
future but what i now want to focus on
is that photon that i emitted at time
equal zero because we saw it moves with
the speed of light in my frame of
reference after one second it has moved
through its x-coordinate is three times
ten to the eighth meters after after two
seconds after two seconds the photon is
at six times ten to the eighth meters
let's see what that photon looks like
from the s prime frame of reference from
sally's frame of reference
well from sally's frame of reference
let's think about that photon after two
seconds
so the photons right over there so t
prime is equal to two seconds
two seconds but what is x prime what is
x prime going to be equal to
well x prime we go parallel to the t
prime axis is three times ten to the
eighth meters
3 times 10 to the 8th meters so in her
frame of reference it took that photon
of light 2 seconds to go 3 times 10 to
the 8 meters or it looks like the
velocity of that photon is one and a
half times ten to the eighth meters per
second in the positive x direction
and this should hopefully make sense
from a newtonian point of view or a
galilean point of view this is actually
these are called galilean
transformations
because if if i'm in a car and there's
another car and you see this on the
highway all the time if i'm in a car
going 60 miles per hour there's another
car going 65 miles per hour from my
point of view it looks like it's only
moving forward at five miles per hour so
that photon will look slower to sally
similarly if we assume this newtonian
this galilean world
if she
if she had a flashlight
if she had a flashlight right over here
and right at time equals zero she turned
it on and that first photon we were to
pat we were to plot it on her frame of
reference well it's going to go the
speed it should be good it should go the
frame the speed of light in her in her
in her frame of reference so it starts
here at the origin and then after one
second in the s prime
in the s prime coordinates it should
have gone three times ten to the eighth
meters after two seconds it should have
gone six times ten to the eighth meters
and so its path on her space-time
diagram should look
should look like that that's her photon
that first photon that was emitted from
that so you might be noticing something
interesting that photon from my point of
view is going faster than the speed of
light after one second its x coordinate
is 4.5 times 10 to the eighth meters
it's going 4.5 times 10 to the 8th
meters per second it's going faster than
the speed of light it's going faster
than my photon
and
that might make intuitive sense except
it's not what we actually observe in
nature and anytime we try to make a
prediction it's not what's observed in
nature it means that our understanding
of the universe is not complete because
it turns out that regardless of what
which inertial reference frame we are in
the speed of light regardless of the
speed or the relative velocity of the
source of that light is always going 3
times 10 to the 8th meters per second so
we know from observations of the
universe
that sally when she looked at my photon
she wouldn't see it going half the speed
of light she would see it going 3 times
10 to the 8 meters per second and we
know from observations of the universe
that sally's photon i would not observe
it as for moving at four and a half
times ten to the eighth meters per
second then it would actually still be
moving at three times ten to the eighth
meters per second so something has got
to give this is breaking down our
classical our new newtonian our galilean
views of the world it's very exciting we
need to think of some other way to
conceptualize things some other way to
visualize these these space time
diagrams for the different frames of
reference